செய்ய முடியும் என்று ராங்கிலுக்கும் வர முடியும் என்று தெரியும். நல்ல டிஸ்கேஷ்ஷின்னு, போ போ நமக்கு புரியும் என்றால் எப்படி இதை செய்யணும் என்று அவர் சொல்லும் பாதி, அதை நாம் அண்டர்ஸ்டான் படிக்க வேண்டும் கர்மாலியோகா புரியும் என்று ஒரு ராங்கிக்கு.
அவர் நிறந்திரம்போது ஒரு இது செய்திருக்கிறார், 'மை பாரத்' அப்படின்னு ஒரு அமைப்பு, போர்ட்டல்.
அதில் ஐயைப்பற்றி நான்கு ரம்பின் நேரம் நிறுவனத்திலும், ஐயைப்பற்றி நான்கு நிறுவனத்திலும், ஐயைப்பற்றி நிறுவனத்திற்குப் பணம் வந்தாலும்.
அதில் நிறுவனத்திற்குப் பணம் வந்தாலும் ரம்பின் நேரம் நிறுவனத்திற்குப் பணம் வந்தாலும்.
உங்களுக்கு என்ன தொழுது என்று சொல்கிறேன் ஞானகனேஷ், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகள் நாம் செய்து போகும், நியானாவிடம் நான் குறிஞ்சுகள் சேர்ந்து போகும்.
இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் செய்து போகும் வேண்டும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் செய்து போகும் வேண்டும்.
இதெல்லாம் நாம் கொஞ்சம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகள் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும்
குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும்
குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும், இந்தக் குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும்
குறிஞ்சுகளில் நாம் சேர்ந்து போகும்